[Music]
i'm
hurt
[Music]
when i heard the news that a one
mr blevins got
the sponsorship
i've been crying since canada i'm back
home now and
i thought i'd be happy i thought that
being back home would make me happy but
it didn't
how could you do this to me
how could you do this to me i've loved
you
since a fan sent me a bag of your
cherished
materials to me in my markiplier mail
series that
will never continue
you were so special to me
oh god no am i snotting
no one loves you like i do no one
certainly not them
i don't blame you
mr blevins i don't blame you how could
you have known
charlie i blame you a little bit
nice time to move on i can't dwell on
things
that clearly won't happen feelings
aren't shared and i get that so
just pull back a bit oh step out give me
some space
[Music]
i'm back home wait hold on my emotions
won't wait
my feelings i'm back home the good old
us of a
with real grocery
roads plumbing i'm back
you know in a bucket was kind
of hard it was fun at first
but got tired of it came back have a
toilet
grocery store and i saw that
i can't even look at you i can't even
look at you
but it's time to move on takis you are
now dead to me
you are in the same list as
corn mitt
green giant the other things that i hate
which are listed here
i pulled down a thing like seeing that's
gonna be hard to yeah whatever okay i'm
here to announce
the new potential sponsorship of the
markiplier corporation
known as doritos dinamita
i've always thought the doritos
dinamitas were far superior
to takis in every single way you can see
that much like
[Music]
takis
doritos dinomitas are the treat that
can't be beta meters
and i'm gonna beat my meat to this
oh look at this
yeah oh look look at the flavoring
you see that zoom in
zoom look at the amount of coding they
hate
they know how to treat a man
[Music]
do you want the takis for comparison no
okay
do you remember yeah
that's the problem i remember
anyway yay powder
[Music]
okay so that didn't work out do you want
to try the chip
why would i do that anyway
i'm here to announce my new sponsor no
no like oh it tastes like oh
like a review like you know when you
yeah when you you food you usually
review yeah yeah
you're right you're right you're right
it's less of a food review more of like
a sponsorship
speed dating
honestly not terrible i can't say it's
the same
but it's close you know
it's like settling
it's because i stopped dying my hair
is that why
anyway it's good doritos call me
or don't hey you know what's better than
doritos cheetos
i'm here to announce my new potential
ship cheetos
flaminate limon
now there is good on the powder
now there is not as much powder on these
but
i do like cheetos i think their
the flavor is very good you know the
cheesy
maybe we should just stop the video
[Music]
all right so um flamin hot
cheetos
it's not enough powder i can't like
suck it off
completely uh there's too much that
sticks to it afterwards so there's a lot
of powder in the crevices
because there's a lot of crevices and
when there's a lot of crevices you know
you'd think more surface area would be
more for the powder but they can hide in
the crevices
and i can't get to them with my
exploratory tongue so
not gonna deal with that i mean to be
fair that bag was already opened
oh that's fine because we do like them
we do like them
but sometimes liking isn't enough no
[Music]
what did i do wrong is it about me not
eating the chip
because really like you think that the
flavor
would matter above all else it's like
the chip is the plate
and the powder is the food you don't
need the plate
it's just a vehicle to deliver the
flavor to your mouth
you don't need the fork that brings food
to your mouth from the plate
you don't eat the chef's hand that
delivers the plate
to your table to the waiter who brings
it to your team you don't need the
waiter
okay you don't i don't anyway
i'm proud to announce my new sponsor
turbo's flamis
i've always loved turbo's flammas
there's something about the spiral
shape that really enhances the
experience it's like a tornado of flavor
in your mouth
[Applause]
oh look at that bright red redder than
red
look at the flavoring just coated in the
crevices
now it might be a problem like with
cheetos where it's crevices but
no no no no no that was a bad idea
not bad yeah flavor great except for the
plate
don't like the plate um but good
like not bad i think actually this is
it's not the same
not as good but it's pretty close like
that's actually pretty good i like
i actually do kind of like it
i think this video might be more
palatable if you are spitting
the plates into a bowl or something
where they're not visible on camera
you know do you know what i'm saying
like a spittoon i do love a spittoon
do you have a splatoon no
do you have a splatoon why would i
always be doing
because she
birthday is next week forget i said that
all right um so that definitely could be
a substitution however
it will really depend on how much money
they want to offer me uh doritos my
minimum
is how much did you take how much did
you pay ninja
how much did you pay him did you pay him
did he pay you
it all makes sense
i was undercut by mr blevins and charlie
whatever her name is
how dare you unless you didn't and then
pay me money
anyway uh sabritas
sabridas pay me um amy what's a fair pay
five million five million five million
five million is my minimum come at me
and we will talk so long into the night
you won't even know when morning comes
forget i say anything
i'm proud to announce my new sponsorship
with fritos
flamin hot corn chips i've always
thought if you want corn
put it in a chip form del monte you're
because i got all the corn that i need
right here in my flamin hot
dish
[Music]
there's no flavor there's no dust
they're not even coated
they're barely anything well i would
love to be able to taste this
but there's no taste to be had anyway um
10 million is my minimum i'm proud to
announce my new sponsor doritos
flamin hot limon i've always thought
unless this is the same doritos as that
doritos which i'm not 100 sure about
that
that's doritos dinomites and i'm
assuming that they're different
departments
doritos flamin hot limon has always
been my favorite form of doritos
i've long yearned for there's no powder
this is a problem
with chips these days why does no other
chip understand this
there's like one factory of takis that
does this right you just
destroy it with powder what is it like
costs
is that the problem are you running out
of powder do you got the powder mines
going and you gotta ration it
just give me a bag of powder with like
one
chip it's like a fun dip thing you get
one stick that you fund it you dip it in
you lick it you dip and lick and dip and
lick
this i just need one one
i just need one
they're the same
you just didn't roll your plate 15
million
this video is proudly brought to you by
lay's stacks
chili lee moon i've always thought that
pringles
was a pringles get because
it's all about lay's
stack that's where the real flavor is
i would make the argument that pringles
are packaged in cardboard as opposed to
a ton of plastic
but are you insulting my future sponsor
that doesn't sound like they're a
sponsor anymore they're paying
they're paying me so much money
environmental concerns
you can't pay me i'm not i'm not for
sale ladies
aren't all of these companies owned by
leis
[Applause]
i don't know oh i get in you
why would anyone like that i've always
thought lays just didn't care about the
oceans
look at all this an entire plastic tube
what is this
hmm what is this
how dare you
nah not worth it i'm proud to be
sponsored by
i'm proud to be sponsored by sensible
portions
veggie straws screaming hot they provide
all the flavor with the nutritious
benefit of vegetable straws
vegetable straw what if you're not
eating the straws
hmm do you eat the straw in a drink
all right so what's the benefit if
you're not eating it
tastes like vegetables where's the corn
god there's the look at it
i'm proud to be sponsored by pito
join the rad cats
join the rad cat the pito's rad cats
you
[Applause]
oh my god it's the saddest thing this is
the amount of powder they put up
there's nothing there's peas
made from peas junk food taste it's
flavor it's junk food
it says junk food taste
i'm proud to be sponsored by
[Music]
if you want just the powder which many
people have told me that this is just
the powder
just get some tahin today
and powder your troubles away
[Music]
pepper
oh
i would do anything anything you ask
i would have done anything and i'm
ashamed to say i'd still do anything for
you
but this hurts you know this really
hurts
i just
i'm okay
can i have the bag can i
can we grab yeah if you could
[Music]
maybe it will be a bad bag maybe maybe
it will be a bad bag maybe
that would be bad
[Applause]
[Music]
nope
um
why can't i quit you
five bucks he sponsored me for five
bucks
i'll do it so cheap for you anyway
i'm back home now freshly vaccinated got
my shot this morning
more videos as soon as i get settled in
there's no resolution for this is there
there's no big hashtag that we could put
glowing right here that we could tweet
it
takis to say give me a sponsorship and
give
markiplier a sponsorship now please
i don't think they'll listen
they don't even have to pay me in money
they would just do just one
bag of powder
it's not so much to ask
i'm not going to come crawling back
i would totally come crawling back
100.
like and subscribe goodbye
good girl